loin du tumulte du carnaval dans un
hôtel 120 personnes ont décidé de jeûner
le concept ne pas s'alimenter durant
cinq jours pour raviver la foi et
trouver des réponses à des questions
existentielles
l'orateur david se base sur son
expérience de vie pour pousser
l'assemblée à l'introspection là ce
qu'il ya c'est qu'on devient parent fait
pour faire la leçon au freezer ceux qui
sont en face de nous mais simplement
pour les indiens moi même je t'ai dans
la boue pauvres
j'étais perdu j'arrivais pas à faire ça
et à faire ça et j'ai essayé le christ
est concrètement sans pouvoir expliquer
en tant que théologien ou autre chose
concrètement voilà ce qui a changé dans
ma vie le concept semble convenir à tous
les âges 17 ans josué en est à sa 3ème
retraites malgré les sollicitations de
ses amis il a fait l'impasse sur le
carnaval
ça m'a un peu dérangé au début de ne pas
pouvoir faire le carnaval passé j'avais
été invité à faire de graves avec des
amis mais je me suis dit faut savoir où
se trouvent nos priorités chacun mais
c'est plus et il y en a qui mettent dans
le travail mais moi c'est dans le
seigneur mois ci dans le senior que je
mets ma priorité et je suis venu à cette
retraite en priorité pour savoir ce que
je devais vraiment fait anormal que je
n'ai à à lure pendant cinq jours je me
suis dit au départ que que jamais je ne
pourrai voilà relever ce défi mais
je m'aperçois au fil des joueurs que ce
qui reste en moi finalement c'est
progressivement ce bien-être cette paix
et ce désir d'aller plus loin avec dieu
concilier jeunes alimentaire et
spiritualité la communauté explique
cette démarche il y aurait un
antagonisme entre la chair et l'esprit
je vais avoir une belle femme je suis un
homme on joue pas en fait les super
héros
j'ai des tentations l'aller à quelques
clics ou devant moi je vais sentir
l'énervement ou d'autres choses mais
tout ça se travaille et le jeune fait
partie des moments où on va à assujettir
la chair quand je vais arriver à la
maison je voudrais pardon à mourir parce
que c'est vrai que je ne peux pas
toujours reconnaître ce qu'il fait je
vais arriver à la maison il a préparé le
repas tout est ok je vais arriver lui
dire mais tu voyais à des gouttes d'eau
à terre et c'est ce que je vais retenir
le mouvement qui se dit n'être ni un
ordre religieux ni un groupe de prière
tout en prenant les fondamentaux de la
bible semble séduire 3 retraite sont
organisées chaque année